[Applaudissements]
une tasse une demi-tasse un tiers de
tasses cassonade sirop d'érable purée de
fruits
on a fait des expériences moins sucré ou
sucrées autrement mais les résultats ne
sont pas toujours concluants
c'est possible de le faire mais il faut
le faire en connaissance de cause le
sucre joue un rôle très important mais
le rôle varie un peu en fonction en face
on regarde tour à ma faim ou un biscuit
la recette la plus difficile à modifier
ses les recettes de gâteaux parce que
c'est une vraiment dans le gâteau que le
rôle du secret le plus important est que
ce rebelle et tpe
expérience gâteau
j'ai préparé un gâteau manning un
classique dans tous venez donc un 100 %
de sucre 1 50% de 35% truc hein avec
sirop d'érable donc remplacement du
sucre littéralement avec les sirops des
rames et un remplacer lé sud par le miel
le sucre va aider au brunissement du
gâteau donc la belle croûte dorée qui
donne une saveur tellement agréable au
gâteau c'est grâce à la bonne quantité
de sucre fait que celui-là 100% il
paraît il on voit qui est quand même
monté droit il fait le petit d'homme
habituel
50 % de sucre ça veut dire on n'en a pas
moins élevé en humilité parce que ce
qu'amène 2 méditez amène la texture
d'une concentration de farine un peu
plus forte d'où le fait qu'ils craquent
comme ça parce qu'il fasse une croûte
vraiment dur l'autre rôle important du
succès qu'il va inhiber le développement
du gluten lorsque trop nuytten qui se
développe dans un gâteau mais bientôt on
va voir une texture caoutchouteuse
os iliaques hui quand même mon relaxer
ou prudents parce que c'est vraiment pas
pareil au goût de la texture de la 1000
ces foules maintenant si on veut
simplement substitué le sucre blanc ou
la cassonade par d'autres éléments
sucrant là aussi on aura des surprises
quand on substitue un sucre sec comme la
cassonade ou le sucre par un autre sucre
sexe serait par exemple le sucre
d'érable ça se fait très bien cependant
très important le sucre d'érable n'a pas
la même densité que le sucre blanc donc
une tendance de ce creux blanc vo peser
davantage qu'une tasse de sucre d'érable
alors on devrait normalement se
substituer poids pourquoi ils n'ont pas
volume pour volume et pour remplacer le
sucre granulé part des sucres liquide il
faudra aussi refaire nos calculs ce
sirop d'érable beaucoup d'eau et très
humaine très liquide mais il ya un
pouvoir sucrant presque équivalent au
sucre fait que ça change vraiment la
donne au niveau
proportion
beaucoup d'humidité ont ils touché
beaucoup plus mines on doit absolument
juste et les liquides parce que dans
latence de sirop d'érable j'ai quand
même pas mal d'eau donc on doit réduire
les liquides de 1/4 de tasse ou 60
militants
c'est donc moi le saas est très bon
vraiment très bon une belle surprise lui
parce qu'il regardait mal au niveau de
l'apparence extérieure
si on utilise le miel il faudra non
seulement à ajuster les liquides mais
faire également d'autres modifications
ouille ouille ouille ouille j'ai
remplacé vraiment l'eau les quantités
similaires à ne pas faire ben non je il
faut vous faut adapter pire des manière
de calculer pour avoir une adaptation
appréciable pour remplacer le sucre par
du iiieme il faut savoir que le miel un
pouvoir sucrant qui est plus élevé que
le sucre à cause d'un certain rang
frutos donc on remplace une tasse de
sucre par trois quart de tasse de miel
tafer caoutchouc oui
on peut vraiment adapté
expérience mof et nous sommes beaucoup
plus simple gfr démarche une aubaine
donc 100 % de sucre 50 % de sucre et le
sucre est remplacé par un bar de pommes
donc pu être pas me réduite de moitié
qui on a les résultats qui sont quand
même assez intéressant armes à feu ce
cas on diminue on change au bruit voir
des variantes au niveau texture mais
c'est moins visible quand gâteau qui
était missionné un foisonner au malaxeur
le chiffre magique à retenir pour une
recette de ma femme c'est qu'on peut
diminuer le sucre jusqu'à à peu près un
tiers de tasses pour une douzaine de mon
film mais attention quand on ajoute par
exemple la compote de pommes on ajoute
une toute petite quantité de sûr mais
beaucoup d'eau la compote de pommes
c'est
85% au real c'est la même compo est sûr
qu on le réduit de moitié d'une
concentration évaporation de l'eau
prendre ce que non finalement pour
l'expérience biscuits de sable et un
vincent % de sucre et à 50% le lui un il
ya là plus sec mais ça enfin rassembler
plus friable mais c'est ce qu'est le
dessus des croquettes en tout
wellink qui est moins qu attendu c'est
probablement la farine que la mesure
accueillent vu que poisse est choquant
qu'est ce que le grain trucks vient
amener un peu d'aération dans la partie
le côté qu paquin du sucre va venir
diminué l'impression farineux du biscuit
aux mauvaises ça vaut à paris mais
couper ou substituer le sucre a ses
limites tant qu'à faire un bon gars pour
on est aussi bien de passes casser la
tête puis de faire la recette tel quel
par contre j'invite les gens vraiment à
expérimenter côté ma ferme certainement
on peut réduire et puis maître du goût
avec des fruits séchés avec de la
cannelle des épices des noix là c'est
vraiment un terrain de jeu et on s'amuse
[Musique]